carlos is calling us from fort
lauderdale carlos how can john and i
help you
hey guys how you guys doing focus and
not finish my friend how are you
yeah pretty good pretty good uh so i
guess i'll give you a little background
it's more of i guess i get to get some
opinion more than
a question directly so i'm 27 uh i live
at mom's house
i work remote so i make around 130 a
year uh
software developer uh so my main issue
is
uh financially i would say my my mom
isn't the most uh
a savvy person you know she's having a
wealthy she's had money coming in most
of her life but recently i'm venezuelan
so uh you know the situation got real
bad so it's
got to a point that her income is more
just on investment
she's racking in around 50 something a
year but she leaves lives
way above her means so you know i'm
having to constantly contribute and
kind of hand her money uh my main i mean
which is not necessarily a problem but
my main problem is just seeing it spend
so stupidly right so like i'll get you
know i'll get friday or something a
random day she'll come in and you'll be
freaking out about expenses and about
money and
so i'll obviously give her whatever she
needs and then the next two days or
three or whatever i'm seeing you know
take out being ordered and
and money just being spent left and
right you know carlos hold on
hey wait you're properly caffeinated
you're ready to roll buddy all right
hold on a minute now
does do you live with your mom or does
your mom live with you
no i live with her see i thought you
said i'm a 27 year old making 130
000 you still live with my mom and i'm
calling the dave ramsey show to talk
about
how she needs to get her stuff together
and so i want to back up a little bit
man like
what are you doing still living at home
making 130 grand
[Music]
i mean i'll be honest man i lived i
lived alone for a few years my mom is
divorced and
it's just to save money i didn't see the
need for me to live on kind of my own
she is
alone now and she has you know she's not
in the best
the best you know spot in her life uh
she went through a bad divorce a few
years back
so you know she's she has a lot of uh
pets in the house it's a lot of hard for
her to kind of be alone right now
sure i'm planning on leaving i'm looking
at houses right now i have my
pre-approval letter
um i used to live a little further away
you know
in georgia actually now well how is she
irresponsible with money like what does
she do you said she'll order some take
out what i mean what else does she do
just living living
above her means right just just kind of
you know if you're making 50 grand a
year you should you know live
under 50 grand a year right so if you
live in a five-bedroom house
uh before because we were you know four
guys and my mom and dad
and now it's just her in a huge house
alone this is not needed right so right
is the home paid for uh
i would say about 60 so i think it's
eight hundred grand i think we have like
500
and are you paying rent while you're
there
i'm not paying rent which is why
obviously i have no problem kind of
passing it along it's just
i hate to see somebody kind of uh you
know my main problem is
is mentally right coming in and freaking
out about finances you know asking for
money
and then spending it instead of spending
it in bills so carlos
carlos brother there's this is a hard
truth there's nothing you can do about
it
you can't um you can sit down with her
you can
buy her financial peace university you
can set a good example but at the end of
the day
one of the one of the most significant
challenges young folks face
is when their grown adults are making
poor decisions or not healthy decisions
or bad financial decisions
and you're just watching somebody you
love make knuckleheaded moves
it's a lot like your parents probably
experienced and they're raising you as a
teenager right making they love you and
you're making knucklehead teenage
decisions at the end of the day you
can't change your mom's behavior yeah
did she freak out when you told her you
were planning to move out
uh yes and no obviously she knows that
she shouldn't freak out but yeah it was
definitely on the negative
side i mean i i think we could make it
obviously work you know it's like i'm
going to be moving out hours away it's
probably like
under a 30-minute drive i guess one of
the things you know
it's been around i don't know uh 50
racks of
50 000 around the past like a year or so
that comes out of my pocket
to kind of fund the excess lifestyle so
i guess should i keep enabling that
it's not a problem because you know
she's not it's not like she's super
negative on the financial side right you
have an investment the 50 grand a year
is technically
off of investment so her explanation is
like look whatever you give me
i'll just give you back from the app she
has that it's just not cash flow right
yeah i think it is i think it would be
healthy for you to have a dollar amount
that you're contributing
uh obviously to the household but i
think more importantly it's this time
frame
that you're going to move out uh and and
go
live your life uh i think that's gonna
be absolutely imperative and giving your
mom
a proper heads up of when that's going
to happen uh i think is important
and you know as you are giving her the
money how she handles it as john said
you can't parent your parent
uh when she gives her that money it's
her money it's hers and so it's be a
matter of pointing her in the right
direction
um you know letting her know uh you know
about the total money makeover and
and for ramsay plus and things of that
nature tools that'll help her
if she's going to use it my friend and
so that's the reality that's tough
but you know like you said you you you
can't be responsible
after you give someone a gift and so
carlos here's what i would do i would
sit down with my mom and say mom
in six months i'm planning on getting a
house and
as part of this transition i'm gonna
start paying rent for the next six
months
and this is the this is the money i'm
going to give you i'm going to pay you a
thousand bucks a month for my room i'll
pay 500 bucks a month for living house
whatever you all agree on
that's the money i'm going to write you
a check for every month and the rest of
it's going to go into my down payment
so she's got six months to plan on you
stepping out
you feel good about paying for this and
it's not this leaking out of your pocket
that's right and um then you can have a
clean transition what we're doing is
putting some structure on this thing
it's a boundary right now it's lucy
goosey that's right
and so now with your mom having six
months heads up she can find a roommate
let her figure it out but don't don't
try to save the day
in that but i do like the idea of having
that structure in that time frame
so you can start to move forward and you
can you know
do it with confidence and know where you
are